as you know we are here in Manchester at
the Conservative Party conference but
this city is controlled by a Labour
mayor and that mayor is Andy Burnham and
he joins us now thank you very much for
being on the program with us and mr.
Burnham you're welcome of course we're
speaking we're speaking at the
Conservative Party conference in
Manchester now something that according
to marketing Manchester is worth around
32 million pounds to the local economy
this week the Labour Party and other
opposition parties voted to not allow a
short recess for this conference which
of course means that as less MPs
spending less time in Manchester
spending less money was that mistake I
don't think so because I think the
government brought the wrong proposal
Sophie to the Commons they basically
said we want our conference in full you
know the complete conference right
through Wednesday through Prime
Minister's Questions if they've gone
with a proposal that said we want the
same conference that Labour had I you
know from Sunday till Tuesday I think
that would have got through and I was
pushing for that behind behind the
scenes so to be honest with you I just
think the government really got it wrong
after last week's Supreme Court
judgement and they lost 11 nil there and
then the Prime Minister goes into the
Commons all guns blazing the next day
you know it should have been more
humility I would have said and a
different tone completely and they
should have said you know we'll do the
same as Labour had you know we'll have a
three day conference and I think that
would have been a a fair compromise just
to kind of say oh no we want the full
thing without any change and the PM lots
of promises questions I don't think that
was a sensible move I just say so we
were laid on a traditional Manchester
welcome today there's one hour later
this afternoon where it doesn't rain so
that's a very Manchester yes well we
were looking forward to that short pause
and the downpours that we've been
experiencing so far that sound something
definitely to look forward to and you
mentioned in your answer and some of the
issues shall we say overshadowing the
Conservative Party confidence one of
them of course these persistent
allegations about Boris Johnson's time
as mayor now you of course on there of a
big city you know about these things
are you concerned about the allegations
around Jennifer our Curie the
businesswoman where there are claims of
course an investigation going on into
those claims that Boris Johnson gave her
privileged access well yes I mean they
are serious allegations I don't know if
they are true or not but of course they
they have to be fully investigated and
we all accept that in the roles that we
do be that as mayor or as minister or as
Prime Minister that comes with the job
so I think it's right that they're being
fully investigated but you know I'm not
going to come on this morning and say
that you know I disagree with everything
that he's done so far what the prime
minister said about northern transport
is promising giving us control of our
railways promising to invest in our our
buses you know these things are positive
and I think having been a mayor and now
being Prime Minister he sees the
challenges that cities like Manchester
are facing but you know what I would say
that the main point I would say this
morning at Sophie is this
take-no-prisoners approach to brexit I
think is unnerving people and that led
to the supercharged atmosphere in the
Commons the other day it was a wrong
approach completely when we had that
Supreme Court judgement you know it's
ratcheting up the atmosphere and I don't
think that's going to help anybody so if
he were ever to listen to me and if I
were to give him some advice you know
last week was a low point this
conference needs to be a turning point
we need to see a different tone I think
the the government needs to start
talking about issues that affect people
the north of England they made a lot of
promises to us Sophie but last week the
government issued figures themselves
that said out of the 100 most deprived
areas neighborhoods in the country 82 of
them are in the north of England
you know hs2 and promises of that
doesn't solve that level of poverty what
will solve it is if they start giving
money to northern councils
again and reversing all of the cuts that
they've made I mean these are the kind
of issues that need to be spoken about
as well as a different toll
on brexit talking about the tone and
it's clear that you have concerns about
some of the language and that we're
seeing in the debates about politics of
a minute I was quite interested in some
things that you said at a conference
this week you said that social media has
completely disrupted our political
system which can't cope do you think
that's a form of radicalization almost
well I certainly felt the change Sophie
I was in Parliament eight years before
social media and eight years after and
you know the second half was was like a
completely different job that that I was
doing I think what it's done is it's
broken down the the collective ways of
Parliament you know Parliament has to
work on those collective principles
through the Tea Room and the PLP in the
1922 committee I think social media has
made people become more individual but I
also feel when I watch Parliament's at
the moment some people are kind of
thinking about the clip that will play
on social media when they're making
their speech and they're not making it
in the let's say the olds more
considered way they're doing it in a way
that's that's playing to a certain
position on social media and yeah I
think it's it's kind of ratcheted up the
whole atmosphere and not for the better
and then there are some ways in which
social media to improve politics in
terms of bottom-up change and people
having a stronger voice but in my view
it did begin to damage Parliament quite
significantly
it was always quite a dysfunctional
world as we all know but social media
has made it much more so and I think now
this is partly why Parliament is
struggling to make sense of what's going
on everybody's in these splintered
positions and you know we're struggling
to find compromise in these quite
polarized times and as I say all
politicians need to take a step back
here moderate the language think about
compromise again they seem to have lost
the art of compromise and I think social
media is is partly responsible for that
too now it's an Conservative Party
conference this weekend I just came to
ask your thoughts about Labour's
conference last weekend where it backed
a brexit position which was to win an
election
trying to go share a deal and
put it back as a second referendum and
it wouldn't confirm how it would
campaign in that second referendum do
you think labour needs to unequivocally
come out full remain no because I think
that would be quite damaging the Liberal
Democrats did that and it appeared to me
that that was a very arrogant move
certainly to the the people who voted
leave and I think that move that they
that they made probably further damaged
democracy further polarized people so I
think labour actually has been the only
party trying to bring people together
across the divide personally I would
have encouraged them to take a slightly
different approach last week
the focus should be on stopping No Deal
brexit and then getting a sensible deal
through that is where I think the
national interest still lies if anyone
was to listen to me I would recommend
now that there needs to be compromise on
all sides and that we should leave the
European Union on a Norway style deal
effectively as an interim position so
that we can kind of honor the referendum
but then carry on debating after we've
left in the years to come what our end
position with Europe will be I mean that
would be a much better way to do things
rather than talking about second
referendums or revoking article 50 I
mean that is kind of a think further
fueling that the sort of distrust of
politics that we're all feeling right
now and as I say politicians have lost
the art of compromise and then they need
to rediscover it pretty quickly because
the only way we get through this is
through compromise on all sides just
finally there's been quite a lot of
speculation after they've a conference
about leadership succession planning
whether or not Emily Thornberry or cast
armor could be potential leaders of the
future now you've had a crack at it
before could you be tempted to run again
I mean the current Prime Minister's a
former mayor well you mentioned my to
twice actually yet Sophie not just once
and you know I mean I lost and I know
many ways why I lost people were looking
for a change and not the sort of
continuity that we'd seen through
the labor governments of the last the
last decade so to be honest I kind of
feel a bit liberated being out of the
the dysfunctional world of Westminster
it never worked for me individually very
much no you kind of have to go with its
strange ways but it didn't work for me
personally but I don't think it works
for the north of England either you know
it is inherently a London centric system
and I think the problem with our
politics over many years has been the
the idea that Westminster is the only
show in town you know we've got a very
over centralized political system here
and I think that that system Westminster
has created the north/south divide it's
never looked after the north in the same
way that it's looked after London and
the south and so you know rather than me
sort of sitting looking like I'm biding
my time here plotting a return to
Westminster actually what I'm trying to
do is is build up English devolution
because I think this is a big part of
the answer to the to the whole the
country finds itself in at the moment
give more power to people put it in
their own hands more equal funding right
across the country that will build a
healthier politics it maybe than the one
we've got right now